100 prozent vergütung ganz ohne kondom
pille und alle anderen bekannten
verhütungsmethoden amerikanische
forscher haben eine neue methode
getestet jetzt bei klicken science
fiction herzstück wäre für die frau
verschiedene varianten gibt zu verhüten
hat der mann eigentlich nur die wahl
zwischen kondomen oder eben direkt einer
vasektomie also der durchtrennung der
samenleiter die wissenschaft sucht seit
jahren nach alternativen
behandlungsmethoden für den mann der
schließlich auch die verantwortung haben
japanischer wissenschaftler der
universität von osaka hatte es zum
beispiel geschafft spermien mit hilfe
von pillen so unfähig zu machen dass sie
nicht in die eizelle einbringen konnten
jedem ist bekannt dass spermien einen
langen weg zurücklegen müssen
auf dem weg dorthin verirren sie sich
oder sind einfach zu schwach ein
spermium das in die einzige einbringen
will darf keine schwäche zeigen der
erste akt erwartet die spermien nämlich
direkt vor dem viel für die sogenannte
hyper aktivierung also das eindringen in
die eizelle brauchen die spermien noch
mal jede menge kraft unter anderem in
form des eiweißes kalt sie in neueren
genauer gesagt in form einer form des
karzinoms p p p 3c ist eine der vielen
form von kalorien und bleibt für die
spermien ausschlag geben
das ziel erreichen zu können mit einem
nennen wir es mal ppp 13 blogger konnten
die forscher spermien von männlichen
mäusen derartig schwächen dass sie als
unfruchtbar gelten konnten vier bis fünf
tage nach der einnahme der medikamente
hätte die wirkung eingesetzt nachdem die
mäuse keine blogger mehr bekommen hätten
wären sie auch schon innerhalb der
nächsten woche wieder fruchtbar gewesen
doch es geht auch ohne blogger
medikamente film experten des california
national climate research center zufolge
ist die antwort klar
ja es geht und sogar zu 100 prozent in
einem artikel erschienen im basic and
clinical oncology fachmagazin
berichteten die forscher von einer an 16
rhesusaffen durchgeführten studie mit
einem in die sammler injizierten vasall
biel konnte ein ganzes
ja die fruchtbarkeit der menschen auf
null herabgesetzt werden das heißt das
einfach ein gel in den warmen leiter
gespritzt wurde und ab diesem moment
kein spermium mehr durchkam
der wahlleiter wurde einfach verstopft
das heißt aber wiederum nicht dass die
affen aufgrund des spiels keinen spaß
mehr hatten das gilt für hindere
lediglich dem warmen austritt bei der
ejakulation zitat wir waren beeindruckt
dass die alternative bei jedem affen
funktionierte obwohl das unser erster
versuch war so angela dawes schauten die
sich das wasser auf den menschlichen
organismus auswirkt das ist noch nicht
bekannt soll aber noch geklärt werden
klar kann es tatsächlich beim menschen
zum einsatz kommen könnte ein jährlicher
besuch beim arzt das neue mittel zum
zweck werden was mit dem gel aber wohl
eher weniger verhindert werden kann ist
die übertragung von
geschlechtskrankheiten also kondome
werden auch in zukunft unentbehrlich
sein
hier könnt ihr mir eure abos aufs auge
drücken und mir im anschluss noch einen
auf die glocke geben
viel spaß dabei und läuft bis dann
bleibt dran